Hello.
Welcome.
This is the second part of our
DevTools tips and tricks.
So in this part, we're going to
take a look at some of the
internals or some of the ways
you can extend DevTools or
even use it in different ways
for different applications
entirely, which I think
is very cool.
So once again, you can follow
along by going to
bit.ly/devtools-tips.
You can see the slides.
You can see the examples.
You can follow the links.
But in the meantime, just check
out some of the things
that you can do with DevTools.
So the first thing that we
talked about in the previous
episode, when we actually looked
at DevTools, was the
Audit panel.
And the really cool part about
the Audit panel, we saw a
couple of built-in audits, like
network and performance.
But you can add your own
functionality into here, which
is really nice.
So if you have any sort of style
guidelines or team best
practices or other things that
you have agreement on with
your team, you can actually
codify them into this plugin,
inject them right into DevTools,
and just hit Run,
and it'll verify.
We have this silly example
here, but I think it
illustrates the point of
Readability plugin, which just
looks at, hey, the font
size on this page
is maybe too small.
It's not legible.
We should bump it up.
So to get this functionality, it
literally just takes about
10 lines of JavaScript.
So first, we're going to add
a new audit category called
Readability.
And then, we're going to inject
the feedback that we
want back to the user.
So we're going to say,
we found two styles
with a small font.
So I guess I should say that
when you run this audit, you
have access to the page.
So you can do all of your logic,
and then, based on
that, you would admit
these rules.
So we found two styles with the
small font, and we can add
severity and other things, and
all of the sudden, you're
looking at this nice report
in Chrome DevTools.
So you can find broken links,
best practices, et cetera.
Now, very, very handy.
So if you're finding yourself
repeating the same work at any
point in time, this
is the tool that
you want to be using.
Similarly, you can actually
extend the panel in Chrome,
which is to say, instead of just
adding functionality into
the Audit panel, you can
put it into other
places within Chrome.
So for example, we've just added
this Font Picker panel,
which can live in all the
various locations.
And you click on an element, you
can have [? contextual ?]
control of that element.
You can actually inject
additional properties, like
what is a font name
and other things.
So if you have your Templating
Engine or some other
framework, you can actually
embed some of the additional
functionality right
into Chrome.
Once again, quite nice.
A little bit more advanced
than Audit.
But nonetheless, this is the
right tool if that's what
you're looking for.
Now, this one is kind
of interesting.
I know that I've certainly
spent--
I feel fine admitting it-- that
I spent way too much time
customizing all of my various
IDs for what's the perfect,
ideal color scheme and font
sizes, et cetera.
Good news, you can actually
do the same thing in
DevTools, as well.
I know that I certainly spend a
lot of time in DevTools, and
I like that to be consistent
with the rest of the system.
So you can actually drop in
your own custom CSS to
re-style all of the style sheets
or all of DevTools.
And you can check out
these slides later.
There's this link to a post that
I put together, which has
a lot of really cool and
nice looking themes.
You can just drop that in and
completely re-style your
Chrome DevTools, which
is quite cool--
and the supplies on
all platforms.
Now, debugging is something
that we get a lot
of questions about.
This is a very, very powerful
feature of Chrome.
So this applies to both mobile
and regular debugging.
So there are two ways
basically to leverage debugging.
One is you start your Chrome
instance with this extra flag
called Remote Debugging
port, and then you
give it a port number.
And similarly, when you're
running on your phone, you
just need to set up
port forwarding.
So for example, I have
my Android phone.
I can connect it
to my computer.
I have Chrome running
on my phone.
ADB is the Android Debugger.
So I'm just going to set up port
forwarding, and then you
can debug your web pages that
are running on your phone but
directly in your DevTools.
So let me show you an
actual example here.
So I'm going to start Chrome
Canary with the
remote-debugging-port=9222.
I'm going to run this.
It opened this guy right here.
I'm just going to
open google.com.
So far, nothing too
interesting.
It works.
Now, in this other tab, I'm
going to do something
interesting.
We know that we are running
the debugger on port 922.
So if I just send the request
to the /JSON endpoint, it
actually returns me a bunch
of metadata about
all the open tabs.
And in here, you can see that
the first tab that is open is,
in fact, google.com, which is
the page that we opened.
No surprise.
And we also give you this
WebSocket Debugger URL, which
means that we can connect to
this endpoint and start doing
interesting things.
And of course, at this point,
you're probably asking what
are those interesting things?
Well, if we go back, one thing
you can do is actually take
another client, which is not
even necessarily DevTools,
connect that tool to Chrome
and drive it.
So for example, here I have
just a very simple Ruby
Script, which will actually
drive Chrome and drive it
through the debugging protocol
that we support in Chrome.
So let's take a look at
what's happening here.
We query this URL that
we just saw.
We fetch the first WebSocket
Debugger URL.
So this would be
our Google URL.
And then we connect
to it, and we just
send a couple of commands.
The first one is network.enable,
which means
that, hey, I want you to enable
network debugging from
this point forward.
I want to get data for this.
So think of it just as in
your Chrome DevTools.
You're clicking on the
Network panel.
That's effectively what
you're doing here.
And then the next request,
request number two, I'm
saying, hey, please navigate
yourself-- so I'm talking to
this specific tab--
please navigate to twitter.com
and search for DevTools.
OK.
So far, so good.
And Chrome will do that, and it
will actually then spit out
all of this network data.
And how is it going to look?
Well, it's going to look
something like this, except
there's going to be lots
and lots more data.
So for example, as we're loading
Twitter, there's a lot
of resources on that page.
You're going to see a lot
of requests coming in.
Here's an example.
We have a request that is being
made by Chrome, and
Chrome was logging this,
saying, look,
I'm making XHR requests.
This is an AJAX request.
I'm asking for the current
trends in English language.
By the way, I got a 200
for this request.
I didn't use the cache.
I didn't reuse the connection
for whatever reason.
And by the way, here's all of
the timing data for this
request-- how long I spent
connecting, doing a DNS
lookup, and other things.
So kind of very low level, but
it's, once again, all the data
you would need to construct
your Timeline or something
else, which actually hints at
the next thing, which is
Chrome DevTools, itself,
is a web app.
So once again, we have our
Chrome Canary here.
So these two are two different
versions of Canary, and this
is a regular version
of Chrome.
So we have the debugger
running on
the one on the right.
So I'm going to go into here
and go to localhost:9222.
This is where we run
the debugger.
And look at that.
We have the tab.
We can see the tab that we
have opened, which is
google.com.
And if I click on this, it'll
load up DevTools.
And you'll notice that as I
hover over the different
elements, it actually
highlights it on
the page on the right.
So this is one instance of
Chrome talking to another.
This is the same workflow that
would happen when you're
running it on your phone.
We're just doing it with
two side-by-side
Chrome run times here.
So why is this interesting?
Well, this really highlights
the fact that DevTools,
itself, is a web app.
And just to prove the point, we
can actually open DevTools
on DevTools.
So if you're seeing double,
that's as intended, because,
for example, as I hover--
whoops.
That's the wrong one.
If I hover on this element
here, you can
actually see it being--
so here I'm debugging DevTools
on the right, which is
debugging this page.
So going a little bit meta here,
but this is very cool,
which means that you
can take this code.
You can actually modify it.
If you have some really awesome
improvement that
you've wanted on DevTools, we'd
love to hear what it is.
You can go right in, modify it,
play with it, and do all
kinds of interesting stuff.
So let me close that.
It can get a little
bit confusing.
Let's go back in here.
So we talked about connecting
to a debug endpoint.
We talked about consuming the
WebSocket feed, and in fact,
that's what DevTools uses.
It connects to the WebSocket
endpoint, consumes that data,
and then just puts everything
to the screen.
But what if something else
generated this debug feed?
And this is an example
I love to use.
I think this is really,
really cool.
So guys at square.com built this
really cool open source
project called PonyDebugger.
And their observation was
that, hey, we use Chrome
DevTools all the time for
developing our web apps.
We'd like to use it for
developing our native apps,
our iOS apps.
So what they did was they
started emitting.
So they basically looked
at our debug
protocol, which is defined.
You can actually find
the docs in it.
And they are emitting this data
straight out of their
native apps, iOS apps.
And their apps are making
requests through the network.
So they're just opening this
data, and they're then
connecting to this WebSocket
endpoint with DevTools.
And they can see all of the data
as you would expect, all
of the network waterfalls,
and all of the rest.
So this is iOS device emitting
these events, and it's
basically debugging it in Chrome
DevTools, which I think
is really, really awesome.
And not only that, but, of
course, you also have Core
Data in iOS.
So they were able to hook up
Core Data and use Chrome
DevTools to drill in directly.
So for example, you have User
Model, and User Model has all
different properties,
et cetera.
So once again, this is Chrome
DevTools being used to debug
not Chrome, but something else
entirely, which is awesome.
Now, shifting gears
a little bit--
benchmarking.
Benchmarking is a very hard
thing to do right, very easy
to get wrong, because you tend
to forget something.
And it's easy to forget
something, because there's so
many different layers of caches,
socket pools, and
other things that are being
maintained by your browser, by
your operating system, your
DNS caches, et cetera.
So we have a very handy tool
that can help you do this
better or do it right.
And to get that running, you
actually need to install an
additional extension.
It's the Chrome Benchmarking
Extension.
You can install it from
the Chrome App Store.
And then to make use of it,
you actually need to start
Chrome with a new flag.
So just like previously we were
using Remote Debugging
flag, here we need to
enable benchmarking.
And what this allows the
extension to do is it gives it
control to be able to close all
the socket pools, flush
those, flush the DNS cache,
all kinds of internals of
Chrome that you don't get
exposed to day to day.
So combining those two together,
they'll help you
automate benchmarking.
And I'll show you this
in a second.
One other tip that I have is
this is specific to OS X, I
should say.
But if you're running on a Mac,
there's this very cool
app that's not related to Chrome
at all called Appify,
which allows you to take any
sort of command with a couple
of parameters and wrap it into
what looks like an app.
So sound simple?
So I have Chrome Benchmark.
I just package it as an
app so I can run this.
Actually, to do that I would
have to quit this.
So Benchmark--
it'll start up an instance
of Chrome.
There we go.
And so we're running with this
flag, and the extension is
right here.
I'm going to load it up.
And it gives me this interface,
where I can type in
a couple of different URLs or,
in fact, as many as you want.
You can load an entire file.
I'm going to just run this
against two endpoints.
So google.com and, let's
say, yahoo.com.
So you can specify the
number of iterations.
I'm going to say three.
We don't have all day.
Clear connections,
clear cache--
I'm not going to test
for a SPDY, but this
can do a SPDY check.
So hit Run and watch
what happens.
So now this extension is
literally opening up these
tabs, firing off these requests,
loads the page,
closes the tab, flushes
everything, repeats this
process, and is going to do it
three times for each of the
URLs we specified.
So this is basically automating
this experience.
And the best part is that it
aggregates all of this data
and gives us a report
afterwards.
So wow, the Yahoo! pages are
taking quite a while to load
for whatever reason.
So now we're loading
google.com.
And you can see that here
we've had three
runs in each case.
As you saw, so we have standard
deviation in the load
time, so one of the pages
took a long time.
So the standard deviation
was really high.
I wonder what happened there.
And we can also just
click on these two
guys and click Compare.
And you can see that the Google
pages were pretty
consistent.
Something funny happened
there.
Maybe it was my network.
But you can see the huge
variation between these runs
for yahoo.com.
So you can put in more URLs.
Definitely use this tool.
It gives you nice metrics for
things like load meantime,
time to first paint, which is
very handy, the meantime, and
a number of other things.
So very handy if you're doing
any sort of benchmarking.
This is the way you
should do it.
And speaking of the internals
of the Chrome networking
stack, there's actually quite
a bit of data that you have
access to if you're trying to
debug the performance of your
application.
So we have the Omnibox,
which-- and this is
kind of on the side.
This is more personal curiosity,
if you will.
But we have the Omnibox, which
helps you with autocomplete
and trying to help you figure
out where you're trying to go.
So all of this data is stored
in Chrome Predictor.
So if you just grab this and
type it into your Chrome and
hit Enter, you'll see all the
predictions that Chrome stores
that you've typed, and you can
see the guesses that Chrome
will make, which actually
makes for quite
interesting to explore.
The other section that I'll
highlight is Chrome
net-internals.
If you happen to play with us,
you definitely should.
There's a lot of useful
tools hidden in here.
So if I go into Chrome
net-internals--
let me go into Sockets, and here
you can see all of the
open sockets currently
in Chrome.
You can actually flush them.
You can close them.
You can do all kinds of stuff.
You can look at your
current cache.
So Timeline DNS, the records
that are being kept by Chrome.
So all this data is in here.
And I'll show you one specific
example for SPDY.
So SPDY is a layer below HTTP.
So when you look at resources
fetched via SPDY, you actually
won't see any difference in
your Timeline, because
basically it's just HTTP.
But they do look different
on the wire.
So right now, we have two
SPDY connections open.
Now, let me show
you an example.
So I have this really silly
spdy.io which just prints
"Hello World." There
you have it.
We can go back into our Chrome
net-internals, and look at that.
We have a SPDY connection that
is currently open to the
server, and we have
the ID of it.
So we can click on this, and
you see the actual session.
You click on that, and all of
a sudden, you see all of the
data as it is on the wire.
So these are the SPDY frames
being exchanged between the
client and the server.
So we're sending a [? Sen ?]
Stream with all kinds
of parameters.
This should look
very familiar.
It's basically HCP,
but it is wrapped
in a different protocol.
So if you're curious about SPDY,
if you want to play with
it, if you want to just explore
it, this is the place
to take a peek and learn
what's happening.
So let's close that
and head back.
Similarly, Chrome stores a
lot of histogram data.
So this is performance-related
data specific to your browser.
This data is collected
throughout the lifetime of the
browser or since
you opened it.
So you can look at things like
what is the average or the
mean or what is the
distribution, actually, of the
DNS look-ups.
So if I open this, there's a
lot of histograms in here.
But if I look for
DNS Success--
let me just look for Success--
Attempt Success Duration.
So you can see that most of the
DNS requests that I make
get completed very fast, so
within zero milliseconds,
which means their cached, which
is exactly what we want.
But then there's this long tail,
and then there's this
funny spike at about
300 milliseconds.
So this is the detailed
histogram metadata about just
your network performance.
So if you have a suspicion that
maybe your ISP or your
DNS server's not working well,
this is the place to find out.
Lots of other data aside from
DNS in here, as well.
So just fun to play
around with.
And the last thing that I'll
mention, and this is more
specific to Chrome, so some of
these other things like socket
pools and other things are
basically present in all the
web browsers today.
One of the nice features of
Chrome is that it actually
learns the topology of
the network or your
site, if you will.
So let's say I have never
visited cnn.com, The first
time I load it, Chrome knows
nothing about it.
So we just go about loading
the page as you would.
But we remember which
sub-domains or which domains
we've used to fetch some
of those resources.
So for example, if you're
putting a lot of your assets
on some CDN and we're fetching
a lot of resources, we'll
remember that.
Such that the next time you load
cnn.com, we will actually
see if it makes sense to
preemptively open that
connection to your CDN.
Such that when you do make that
request for the asset, we
already have the connection
open, and it
can be fetched faster.
Now, that doesn't mean that
Chrome will do that every
single time, but in this example
for igvita.com, you
can see that these are the
resources that we remembered.
We know that this page uses
the Google Fonts.
It uses a Plus Button.
It uses Google Analytics.
So we've remembered those, and
next time around, we may
actually use this information
to speed up the
performance of your site.
So very interesting and fun
to play around with.
And you can go into the
Chrome/DNS and look at these
host names and see what's
happening there.
Now, this last one here
is chrome://tracing.
Very powerful, very
interesting.
It was originally built by
and for Chrome engineers.
So we were trying to figure
out how to improve
performance of Chrome.
What's actually happening in
the guts of Chrome, itself?
But a lot of people have started
using this, because it
is, in fact, very useful, not
just for understanding how
Chrome works, but how your code
interacts with Chrome code.
So for example, if you're
running, or if you're writing
a game or something that is
really exercising all of the
features of Chrome and really
trying to leverage the GPU and
other things, this is definitely
something that you
want to check out.
And there's a great article
on this on HTML5 Rocks.
But let me show you what
this actually does.
So we can go into
chrome://tracing--
whoops.
Chrome://tracing, we can hit
Record, and let's go to one of
these tabs.
And there we go.
We'll just scroll around for
a little while and go back.
Hit Stop.
Now, we have a lot of different
tabs open, so you
see the individual threads of
each tab and how those are
interacting.
But right here, we have
a bunch of activity.
So this is the Renderer
thread.
And we were just scrolling, and
we had that kind of slow
interaction.
So the Renderer was doing
a lot of working here.
And we can actually zoom in
on this region and see.
So this is--
or these are other-- the
specific frames that are being
rendered, and this is the
work that's being done.
So we continue zooming in, we
can pan around, and we can see
the actual work.
So we have a Render widget
that's calling.
So these are internal
names within Chrome.
So if you want to find
out what Chrome is
doing, this is fantastic.
And we can continue zooming in,
and we can see that at a
specific frame here, we're
actually drawing the pattern.
So we're calling a function
within Chrome called Image
Draw Pattern.
And this is what's outputting
those Chrome logos.
But if you want to find out
more as to how that works,
perhaps you're trying to
debug something, that's
the way to do it.
But not only that, this, by
itself, is kind of useful
because you get to peek inside
of Chrome and figure out maybe
you have a performance
bottleneck that you just can't
figure out.
That's the place to figure
out what's happening.
But even better, you can
actually inject your own
labels into here to figure out
where is my code and how does
my code interface with
other code within the
internals of Chrome?
So to do that, in your apps, you
can use console.time and
console.timeEnd to mark
a start and an
endpoint for any interval.
And then, in this case,
I'm saying update.
And if we repeated the same
exercise and then zoomed in on
that specific section, we
would actually see these
blocks here-- so update
and render.
So this is your code running
within the context of all the
other code within Chrome.
So if you're really pushing
the performance of the
browser, this is a great way to
get a full picture of not
just high-level JavaScript
API.
And that will give you access
to CPU-GPU and many, many
other things.
So with that, that's all the
tips we had for now.
You can check out the slides,
and I encourage you to do so.
There's a lot of links that you
should explore in there at
bit.ly/devtools-tips.
Thank you.